congiu ragazzini e benvenuti a questo
nuovo script tutto io episodio che da un
po che non facevo su giochi incredibile
comunque proviamo a fare una partita
decente visto che da un sacco di tempo
che non ci gioco
vediamo però due lettere poi due lettere
se così come due lettere e macomer e la
cosa c'entra la lingua siamo io siamo in
due siamo solo io e calamaro perché gli
altri allettato sono solo io e il
campione indiscusso proprio lui grazie
grazie a tutti i ragazzi grazie io me la
cavo in questo gioco qui proviamo non
posso partecipare in questo perché già
partita bella ti va quella è una torta
di compleanno e un candelotto di
dinamite candelotto divina non di in it
non scherzavo scherzavo cagate potete
una cacata scatola di fiammiferi la
stessa cosa in piccolo ci sono due fa vj
qua come possibile vagone c'è un altro
fa vj che mi ruba il posto bastava vj
you're the fake famosa mista a cupido
proprio lui il vero fa vj si riconosce
dalle risposte date subito proprio
l'azzeccata guarda all altro che sbaglia
se fossi stato quello vero a quest'ora
avresti indovinato impostore viber facci
sognare bea kamau da recuperare fa vj
fake dai eco sentiamolo euro e dragone
verdone a e una lucertola alligatore no
cipolla indovinato maledizione mandrillo
armadillo cos'è cos'è ne hai una puzzola
ma non sembrava proprio no sembrava
tutto tranne che una puzzola all'inizio
adesso è tutta uguale cioè in realtà e
lei è stata bravissima a disegnare bea
bravissima se ora questo se veramente è
la madonna quanto bella sta puzza
mamma mia quanto difficile cioè
all'inizio perché non era colorata come
ha fatto indovinato
pro brava disegnare complimenti di
sicuro meglio di me tutto questo sono
ancora dietro fa vj devo recuperarlo
ragazze madonna che tristezza slider man
ai mio luminoso michelin michelin e
francesca spinge rilassamento grazie
grazie sono fortissimo il più veloce a
scrivere vince faceva cagare
effettivamente un bonus per la simpatia
in tutto questo io sono ottavo e sono
dietro a quello che sta scrivendo la
porco del demonio di parola perché io
adesso vado a perdere ve lo dico io che
perdono dico io
porco il demonio lo perdo questo la mia
vittoria sta nello stare avanti a
l'impostore non riuscirò mai chiedo
volete due io ovviamente guarda come
disegna questo atomo è stato anche
proprio perché hai disegnato bene però
ero troppo impegnato a spiegare il
perché tu e di falso comunque è un atomo
veramente bene secondo me l'ha dovuto
cercare prima su google immagini di
uscita sta roba e poi ha detto ah bè
facciamolo va bene quindi è lui quello
vero
cioè io sono uscita arrivare a dietro
l'altro dietro perché l'altro era già
troppo avanti ma faceva cagare faceva
cagare e ios è uscito arrivare dietro di
lui voglio morire voglio morire li
facciamo ragazzi altra partita non vale
però dai cheppallle tusa world teppista
fascia nunchaku teppista fascia bassa
dai la faccia è facile allora ragazzi
prestata attenzione guardate il vero
famiglie come disegna non quella altro
che un impostore di uno schifoso ok che
se la faccia un po ambigua vabbé non
importa questo è un uomo un pò ambiguo e
ora guarda questo era questo che è molto
facile molto facile allora è facile rega
è la sto facendo semplicissimo eccola
qua e dai è facile è facilissimo
gli ho fatto ti faccio anche il pp
eccolo
certo che sono però fa vicino vedi come
disegno bene porco del demonio e
quell'altro è scarso come la morte
arriva dobbiamo dire ma da era facile è
una fascia si capisce che un apache ah
ah ah cosa era facilissimo porca vacca e
sheepo la salsa picanto orologio ruota
biciclett bicicletta un monociclo ma sei
bravissimo in tutto questo comunque me
la cavo ai ragazzi ce n'è neanche male
l'altro non è anche fatto una non anzi
katane anche una mano ci monociglio the
border a monociclo poi genera indovinato
niente quello fei vai vai provaci dai e
fake prova ce e b e c
niente facile te sei cagato addosso e un
cavallo a zoccolo zoccoli porco di tua
mamma [ __ ] non so comunque in tutto
questo primo a faccia di quello di prima
allora dieta lana mais mais lo facciamo
una bella scodella bella disco the hole
a lei bellissima scodella belluscio ok
questa sì comella spetta che devo fare
il mais allora questi sono pallini mai
il mais il mais e giallo il mais e
giallo il mais e giallo non il riso non
e l'orzo il mais ragazzi e giallo non
sono i semi non sono le uova sono mai si
vede cous cous cous cous con e giallo
cous cous cous cous
il mais e giallo mais il mais e semi
sono marroni il mais e giallo madonna
regala pannocchia una pannocchia ok una
pannocchia facciano qualche volta presso
la parrocchia
io mi sono impegnato comunque vabbè mi
ha superato si può a madonna che round
mare spiaggia ombrellone quella una
palma è un albero palma spiaggia cocco
isola deserta e un cocco palma palme la
palma sulla spiaggia una palma i caraibi
e un non lo so tropicale ei open
cartello insegna scritta negozi negozio
porta aperta aperto orario apertura a
pretura orario o aperto cartello scritta
targhetta orco demonio cos'è ma cos'è
aperto allora non l'ho scritto polpette
artificiosi comolli ti farai vincere
sopra il nome di questa roba sul nero
poi tra qualche alberello portone
porcone pomello e la pomello era pomello
sul serio bellissimo che idea pazzesche
attenzione posso recuperare il primo
posto anzi sono già al primo posto
scroto non era proprio quello credo che
comunque consentita tivo meglio di chi
gioca questo gioco sia elevato tombale
cipolla non vale porco demonio quanto
manca o 20 punti di differenza
godo come un riccio l'ultima cosa
sbagliata e ho perso ragazzi questa è
l'ultima
questa mi sa che l'ultima va i fan di
lion sono sicuro che farà il disegno
capolavoro appena nato da poche ore
ok casermone cavolo è sta roba per
mercato spazzati via se io non mi medico
la vittoria non è un merito io che da
quell'obbrobrio è uscito supermercato
l'indovinato subito io veramente non lo
so io ho indovinato supermercato da
quello sgorbio la cioè io non so
veramente non so se non dico io sta
partita non la merita nessuno da quella
roba un grande supermercato e io me ne
andrei proprio ciao ciao net tv che
finito il tempo che era l'ultima noto
came anaconda quanto va bene più anti
dalla nonna metto consigli guarda è
facilissimo si vede che un guanto yes
si vede che è un guanto si vede che un
guanto si vede che è un guanto si vede
che è un guanto è un guanto perché una
mano è normale questo in quanto questo
in quanto questa è l'acqua
ok la donna è facile lega era veramente
facile con lineari superato perché l'ho
fatto indovinare io adesso è finita la
partita scivola esclusiva guardarsene do
vinho la sua ho vinto essendovi non ha
solo vinto vero attenzione non dovrebbe
farmi dominare teoricamente vomito ora
lui che bello se veramente bravo a
disegnare il vomito cavolo lori mai
detto ma che bravo ti merita liste la
vittoria guarda forse ho vinto io vada
meriteresti duramente al sushi pesce
salmone
mamma mia
l'olio che nyt quanto è servito
bellissimo hai fatto benissimo
410 tensioni avervi dovrei teoricamente
aver vinto proprio lui che se la giudica
e stato bellissimo ragazzi io concludo
qua spero che questa dimostrazione di
superiorità del disegno vi sia piaciuta
e come sempre ci vediamo ora un prossimo
vi do bella ragazzi
[Musica]